so as far as any of the specifics here
it all appears to start with a Discord
message from a streamer by the name of
lavaloon back in September with her
saying there I think Hassan's outraged
about everything is really funny because
he slept with my friend when she was 17
and he was 24. with a streamer by the
name of Judd logic featuring this
message in a stream yesterday and the
clip showing the message gets around and
as of recording it has over 160 000
views now with this many were pretty
skeptical about the obligations because
lavaloon apparently is fought with
streamers in the past and then as it
started gaining traction she changed
some of the details in her story saying
in a sense deleted tweet that the
relationship between Hassan and her
friend was legal and saying that her
comment was about Hassan allegedly
partaking in an adult relationship with
a woman five years as Junior they're
going on to say on patreon Hassan [ __ ]
slept with my very young friend when he
was not so young it was legal but he's
denounced men publicly for doing much
less I don't care about it and she's
never going to come forward but the fact
exists nonetheless an example of
hypocrisy and adding let me be clear
she's not coming forward because she
doesn't care because none of this was a
big deal it was legal I barely cared
asan did nothing illegal probably
nothing immoral either and so
unsurprisingly all of this makes its way
back to Hassan and he responds to the
allegations in a stream and there say
the woman in question was 19 at the time
of their relationship such a ridiculous
slanderous lie this person
makes it so that other people have an
even harder time believing women it's
already hard enough for women to come
out what the [ __ ] are you doing so
Philip defend you actually missed a lot
of context so this woman in question has
been running around a bunch of streaming
spots and a bunch of discords saying
she's got this nuke that she's gonna
drop on her son it could be career
ending it's going to expose him Sons I'm
about to drop a Hassan nuke oh
God damn it
laugh you're gonna end your whole
[ __ ] career on this [ __ ] don't do it
not in a good way literally it's not
worth it I know so but every time his
name is brought up I'm like vibrating no
but you shouldn't wait stop just know
Hassan is well known in Los Angeles no
and then she comes out with the fact
that he was sleeping with a 17 year old
and then after she gets called out she
walks in back say no actually it was a
19 year old it was completely so when
you were running around saying it was a
nuke before Miss what was it like 17.
which is a pretty big deal it's a whole
different yeah hey it's it's it's the
difference between cops cheek and a dude
being even your cheeks you get me I see
how you're talking and she's done this
numerous times yeah she's a she's a
Serial liar uh she's a Serial
um all I know is this [ __ ] is lying
okay and she been lying
that's crazy and let me ask this okay
that's great this is why I think it's
interesting because previously she
called another man basically the uh
Harvey Weinstein of twitch and then
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
trying to say you usually calling these
dude like it's like no no no no no
actually I walked that back I shouldn't
have said that I should not
have made the Harvey Weinstein
comparison I shouldn't have
I will walk it back ever I will walk it
back completely I was like
you just casually just be calling people
some of the worst villains alive and you
think that shit's acceptable you at some
point to me you know what the [ __ ]
you're doing
you know your power if if it was a
one-time thing I still can't trust your
ass I can't trust you but if you if you
do it a bunch of time you know what the
hell you're doing and then you're gonna
come back and then you're gonna come
back and do it again because you know
what you're doing because you know
you're not going to get caught
privileged let's see I think my brain is
fine I think well I just don't I just
don't think before I speak I just need
to be more P I'm just impulsive I'm just
impulsive and [ __ ] I'm like I'm I'm
obviously severely mentally
illness
that's the excuse afterwards because the
first time you said that [ __ ] I'd be
like
all right that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing to do but hope you learn and then
you do it again and again and again and
again and again and again nah nah be now
you gotta know how serious this [ __ ] is
the first time you got caught doing it
right and then you're like I'm impulsive
and it was [ __ ] up and everything and
I'll be like hey you still a stupid
[ __ ] and I can't trust you but
you can't use the same I'm just
impossible no no I can't I was I was
when I was a kid I was impulsive
I was slapping [ __ ] left right
and Center
yeah you would cross me I would slap the
[ __ ] out of you no questions what what
the [ __ ] you say Wow first I'm like I'm
just impulsive the next few times people
are like nah you gotta [ __ ] hold
yourself because
ain't cute when you're nine it's gonna
pass when you're 12 cops are coming you
understand what I'm saying you become a
whole threat you have to understand that
the first time we get it but no you
can't use the same excuse over it no
girl no no I have money I have money but
I'm not buying it
hold up hold up hold up you're impulsive
your impulsivity is not something
separated from you you are the
impulsiveness do you understand what
that means
I don't get to punch a [ __ ] in the face
and be like uh I got anger management
issue as if that matters oops you going
to jail stupid I got I got ADHD I I
can't focus and I just stuck my dick in
a random [ __ ] that's not how it works
like people use this mental health [ __ ]
as if it's a get out of the jail free
card to explain away your irrational
Behavior you got a problem okay guess
what that means you gotta learn to work
with your problem just because you have
BPD does not mean you get to treat
everybody like garbage and not be
accountable for that that's not what
that means it means that you are doing
everything in your power to mitigate as
much of the hurt as you you are doing
and if you hurt somebody you still need
to be accountable for that it makes it
more understandable but it doesn't make
it any less wrong you understand
let's keep listening whatever I'm a bad
person to don't take any don't don't
take me seriously I guess I don't know
clearly I I clearly I'm not okay clearly
I'm not okay I'm very mentally ill
I don't know if I should be in this
space but now I I don't know I I'm
mentally ill now
really when people have told you before
to take accountability over the years
you said no I got a lot to say all this
stuff now that shit's really coming down
you're mentally ill and you shouldn't be
in this space damn it's unbelievable how
people try to escape accountability did
you guys see that like a snake in the
grass you know what it is
people are using this mental health
thing to do a lot of things the same way
some men are using
being gay
whenever they do things other man
Kevin Spacey
when he was when he got called out so I
want oh you know I'm gay he came out
that as there is such thing as gay
privilege for those kind of kind of
things and it's the same thing whenever
you use oh yes it's not me I'm a bit
crazy stop me
here's the craziness talking
no no maybe I don't interact with you
before you do something about it I I
will never [ __ ] do anything about it
that's the question that way when are
you gonna do something about it that way
now let's let's listen to her response
here we go
I believe the individual in question is
liking shout outs to you let's go where
we'll stand up
no bring that [ __ ] back I did not hear
properly
I shouldn't have said anything
I'm very impulsive maybe I don't
interact with it
before you do something about it I I
will never [ __ ] do anything about it
wow
I heard right
wow
I I heard right I thought
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and white noise
I've been I've been a streamer for three
months give me a like let me how many
times do you have to get into these
situations before you realize [ __ ] maybe
I need to step back and consider how I
behave on stream and what I say publicly
she's been on this ship for three months
no and how many okay how many times did
it happen
three times
three and three and every month there's
a new [ __ ] she been on Tick Tock and she
been you know she's got a bunch of 500k
followers for like almost two years okay
so she's lying again she lied she can't
stop lying she's she's acting like no
she's lying
I'm obviously severely mentally ill I
dissociate constantly like I don't know
I don't know like what is real and what
is like there's a here's not real I'm uh
extremely underdeveloped socially now
take all of that and I do not like I
don't I don't know I don't know what to
do I don't know what to do I know that I
made a mistake I feel [ __ ] bad it's
fine let's erase everything that's
happened up to this point you're gonna
go forward from the Stream
trying to make a change that is the key
and I don't know if I am and you can't
hold right I don't know oh
it always comes back to me why why my
face this is a sickness of the highest
order we have discovered that you are
allergic to accountability in America
you can do this you can go and say this
one he's eaten my child and then they're
going to say but you've never given
birth ah I'm [ __ ] I'm stupid but we
have created a society that rewards
people for having a sickness look at
this one imagine you are nobody then you
say somebody touched you like this they
went they just grabbed your balls like
this and they tickled all of a sudden
you're on every mainstream news we have
rewarded people for engaging in
deception
yeah imagine if you have come out you
are nobody and you say ah Hassan this
man he has raptured my anus so to me we
don't want this on the sickness whenever
we're talking about uh fake allegations
that's not what we're talking about by
the way for those who are wondering
whenever they talk about well yeah but
there's only three percent of Faker like
this is not one of them because that's
not reported let me take a step further
she'd reported another dude before these
two right and everybody celebrated her
go Queen you're so brave she told us the
details of the story you know what
happened this is what you claimed happy
she said she went on this date with this
dude they were flirting they went back
to his place and then I and then I made
a and then I I made like a joke about it
my first video was like LOL that one
time when like uh this like La comedian
like kind of forced me to eat his ass
when I was like pushing against him lol
um and it was just like a funny video
funny that sounds really extreme and
this might be a bit [ __ ] up but like I
feel like eating ass has got to be one
of the hardest things to force someone
to do a whole lot oh my God
there's her on my head
it's like keeping my mouth full and
making sure that he was not made me eye
contact with me so I couldn't say no
like it was very weird I wouldn't say
that he raped me but it was definitely
like a very strange situation and
basically she was eating them from the
back and then she went home and I kept
thinking myself do you know how hard it
is to force someone to do something for
you while you're on all fours
and leave behind you and these prayer
foreign
[Laughter]
give it to me now
[ __ ] kill you oh wait let me not aim
at my own [ __ ] no it would be funny
if he holds the gun in his butt cheek
he's just like give me your money
get it yeah put it in the pocket put it
in the back pocket again yeah yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] let's laugh no y'all
laugh at this one she's made up two
times you think the first one's real
she's made up two times why should you
trust anything this [ __ ] says that's
the ammo right now that's the ammo that
you guys asked me why do people lie I
don't know she don't even know she said
she recorded she crazy people ask you
laughs
no no we're not laughing I don't know
imagine if there's a CEO rapist out
there and he's just out here getting his
ass eaten just bending over like eat my
[ __ ] now with this at back Cali but I'm
scared
walk away
you scared while the guy's like
screaming yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sorry
didn't mean the reason why I say this
because like
if you've ever had your ass eaten you
know how much of a vulnerable and weak
position it is you don't have to have
your ass even to know that there's you
know I'm just saying when you get your
ass even from the back it's very hard to
look manly dude I mean you gotta arch
your back it's already a wrap or it's
hard to look stuck down and have your
back arched or you have your legs behind
your head
that was a crazy
laughs
he was being very menacing oh yeah
okay
[Music]
okay we'll see this whole time like I I
always admit this I have a big bias
against white women
I
but part of that is like informed by my
personal experience and I've seen the
way Society reacts to them and like
white women just I don't know what it is
but they just make the most sympathetic
victim they understand how to cry on
demand and do whatever it is to like
sympathize and not all y'all cause
plenty of mad cool but I just know it's
like the best victims have always been
like white ladies for some reason right
I've had like
so the situation I've had women I've
never met I've never seen never spoken
to like damning people around me being
like yo Abba Abba came to my school when
I was 16 in Oklahoma and he said hi to
me and now he won't return my calls now
that I'm 19. and I'm like [ __ ] I ain't
never been to Oklahoma and I ain't
talking no goddamn 16 year old who the
[ __ ] this girl bought patreon accounts
was messaging other creators and I'm
thinking like yo this is crazy but the
thing is you can't defend yourself too
hard
how do I prove something that did not
happen exactly how do I prove I don't
know this person they can fabricate DMs
I can't show you a message history that
doesn't exist it's like it's like it's
like when Amazon asks you give us a give
us a proof that you didn't receive the
email how
I sent a picture of me like this
so you're gonna arch your back [ __ ] I
was like don't do that [ __ ]
give me give me that email [ __ ] I have
nothing
it's like we laughing right now because
you gotta laugh but like this shit's
frightening for real for real right so
we got to cut this whole belief in the
windshield because
after these last four or five years
we've gone to Great Lengths so many high
profile stories have come out and you
see guess what just like men [ __ ] be
lying too right so
cut this movement out stop this whole
idea of inherently believing people who
do not present any factual evidence of
what has happened and it's got to be a
lot of evidence not some [ __ ]
recording that's like edited by the
person themselves actual evidence
because we still live in a society with
minimal evidence women don't get the
whole media behind them Hassan's very
fortunate in this regard the person who
was coming at him is a [ __ ] suffer
immediately
for someone who's a little bit more
Savvy someone's a little bit more
strategic this could be far more heinous
and it would have been much more
difficult for him to defend himself as
heinous is having to eat a man's [ __ ]
against your will
okay
anything you want ahead no
I thought you would turn around
turn it off